shooby dooby dooby gang let's go the
state trashy tour is in full swing we're
coming to a town near you we got the
first leg announced yes we're coming
other places first leg coming up grab
the squad come to the show yeah guys
starting in March we're gonna be in
Baltimore Virginia Beach Richmond
Virginia Oklahoma City Dallas Texas
Houston Texas Austin Texas then in April
New Haven Connecticut Burlington Vermont
in May we're hitting Tampa Dania Beach
Florida there you go Raleigh North
Carolina then in June we're hitting
Cleveland and Columbus we're going to be
announcing a bunch more cities but
tickets are already moving now get them
let's party yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage hey little shall we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that if they're good to be
classy yeah they're just a big old piece
of trash I'm your host Dave trolley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at antodi's basement she's
upstairs motorboating a teenager okay
now all right I'm listening what's
happening my co-host is coming at you
from across the table he is the CEO of
Ru garbage he is an international
businessman the nicaraguans wanted to
run for president and the Russians want
him dead give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan
you're talking about my Russian
neighbors how about that yeah what I'm
an international Man of Mystery that's
right yeah oh they're watching you
speaking of we'll get into that ooh ooh
shout out to everybody thanks for tuning
in well you saw Austin Powers this
weekend we did yesterday me and T-Bone
so I'm like Myers no yeah we had dinner
with the Stars baby all right a little
meal you two dirt packs had dinner
together uh-huh no I don't like that
I said don't tell fully wait till the
show oh okay along with my wife as well
Luke find your best pair of sweatpants
Uncle Hanks taking you out to dinner
we're going to Carbone's table for three
um I'll call that Bradley Cooper right
now uh please make sure you rate view
subscribe on iTunes whole video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are
rap good and obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com
episodes of hard feelings
oh hang out I'll be letting it hang out
here it's gonna be a little hard
feelings I think find out about this
dinner uh and then uh guys uh we're
announcing our new tour dates the link
should be in the bio they're announcing
soon get those Dickies when they're
available yeah and having a nice quick
shout out to our producer X Jordan Air
the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones and twos crosses the t's
dots the eyes I bought them thinner
didn't even know it give it up for
T-Bone mcgruffins Toby McMullen
everybody hey what's up dudes what's up
T-Bone oh nothing just out there
hobnobbing with New York royalty you
know we're just go dinner Mike Myers was
there what where'd you go I had him over
my apartment it was it was a Catered
Affair
I made I made him wear the outfit though
I said Mike you can hang do but I need a
lot you know those little song and dance
or something hey do the voices for my
wife where's Dr Evil at I never seen you
throw in the same room talk to the dog
like it's mini me huh come on where'd
you have dinner uh Donald or east side
down there yeah where uh better be a
Subway
a place called Ruby Rosa really uh-huh
I've been wanting to go there tough
reservation tough reservation again I
pulled a couple of strings me and a mic
man yeah Schultz to get you a table no
they know me Mike Myers was in there
Mike Myers sat right next to us and then
answer his table to be changed from away
from Toby
Toby was in there cackling talking about
camera lenses or something Myers wanted
out is that true that is 100 right
do you want to cackle the buildings
Rattle and Myers sat down for two
seconds because uh waiter change my take
you walked Mike Myers well in our
defense they had status in the kitchen
because was he solo he was with his kid
ah and then Toby I go that was Mike my
Toby and my wife didn't realize they had
nothing you brought the bird too yeah
what what am I the last man on the team
Junior man I need countless
you were sick idiot oh Luke you
and your girlfriend are in for a
treat for a nightmare
[Laughter]
oh man
that's a good piece of business
uh I just pooped my pants a little bit I
was like Jesus Christ
I'm getting over a stomach bug I don't
know what to tell you we'll be all right
um I wanted to ask you speaking of which
I know both of you aren't gonna like
this if your question is does he look
like in the movies exactly like in the
movies uh-huh he smelled nice too
he really lights up a room at Eminem
Eminem
and King Bozo fashion those two didn't
realize and I'm like of course he walks
in I see him you know a star spot Stars
you know sure
other famous people sense other famous
people in the room
you play a Rock in something
can you play an old man can you play the
boulder that chase Indiana Jones
down the cave
um I don't like this he was sitting
there with his kid like right next to
Tebow because those those uh they're
tight spots tight spots the Lower East
Side spots you're on top of each other
which I hate I'll give me two three
tables next to me too I need a little
Elbow Room hmm
um I go that was Mike Myers too because
I was a kid I'm like yeah not him you
idiot Mike Myers was Mike Myers
that was clearly his son
he goes that was a kid he works here
getting jobs King Bozo move anywho
um
I wanted to ask you about uh the wipes
about butt wipes okay
obviously fresh ones sure can you use
them
for anything else is that trashy
ah because I use them if I if I tinkle
and I dribble a little bit I'll take a
throw a couple on the floor and I'll
clean it up like that use your foot
though I use my foot yeah that's the
Trashy thing why using your I mean
using your foot to clean that's not I
mean that's not how they do it in the
commercials what are you talking about
dude what do you mean why I'm not saying
I don't do it I'm the kind of guy if I
got a sock on and I dribble I'll just
mop it up with the socks
I'm old school baby
I'm old school Janice you can't use
appendages as piss mops squeezing your
foot is a wet chat yes Swiffer
it's called the Kippy baby commercial of
me zipping around the zipping around the
apartment they should have those my feet
smell like fists they should have well I
usually take my socks off and the dog
eats them so it's a selfie yeah
he's got a mark of my territory but I
also wipe down like the sink with them
and stuff like that that's cool yeah all
right
okay
I'll take it away Kippy
I thought I'd get a little more pushback
for that I didn't know you were wiping
up your pee with your foot uh that's
crazy I've done it I don't make a habit
out of it but I've been walking around
the house ah I mean I first of all not
like it's it's not like a puddle on the
ground it's a drip drop so I don't get
yelled at you know on the subject I do
have something else to confess
ah
more often than not
I'm peeing in the shower
just like not in the shower not in the
shower what are you doing because like
if I get it all over the place it's a
problem I get yelled at that's what
squatters do man you can't be doing that
I run the water
and it saves water how does one in the
bathtub save water every time you feed
I'll fill it up that way but you're nuts
I just give it a little splash it's no
good no Toby that's like Fenway Park
bathrooms dude that's like a trough
might as well throw some ice in there
like a like an old door in a little Pub
next to a guy in a Giant's hat hey they
look good this year huh you believe
these bums
pass interference
oh god well you doing ice baths he says
nah it's just pain in the top it's just
easier for everybody
that's the way I look at it okay fair
enough I completely disagree I turned
the fan on I turn the water on on the
phone I have to do it
the fan have to do it just to cover it
up she don't know this what are you nuts
I could be out on the street yeah it's
where you belong you're peeing in a tub
yeah that's no good huh no knock that
off all right
then I gotta sit down and pee I don't
want to do that yet or you can just
stand up hey my I'm too I'm too powerful
that's I'm telling you I can't talk
about an all-time Spin Zone I'm telling
you man
I'm too powerful what does that mean for
escalators Maybe
I'm too powerful no matter where I hit
the toilet it splatters out and like
little little particles I think you got
bad aim I don't have bad aim I got good
aim
it's coming out it's like a fire hose
all right yeah Easy Does It This way
everything stays clean and no one's none
the wiser yeah all right it's got to be
real careful when I open and close the
thing because they weave the metal hooks
and she's going while you showering four
times a day
at least you don't smell like you are
yeah knock it off with that seriously
all right I uh I I I really I have a
problem I went out to dinner with them
we wait we had a nice little uh dinner
and a movie date yeah we've had a couple
of dinners over the last week yeah I do
all right what happened back on the
sauce yeah no uh you turn that key
real quick what you you were drying out
you were dried out for like 23
days you were on the Peloton next thing
I see a picture on Instagram you got you
got you got four cows legs a bone marrow
in front of you yeah they build my drink
all over the table man I don't belong in
nice places dude they spot I did I was
wearing a Miller a Miller a Miller High
Life racing t-shirt at a place in a bone
marrow yeah it was Minetta what yeah and
I spill I spilled my Manhattan all over
the table I I can't take me to nice
places I Resort back to that
eight-year-old scared what's your
Suburban Diner what'd you put the bone
marrow on
bread or Crap a little behind my ears
relaxes me at night
where it is cologne uh what are you
putting it on oh a baguette they do yeah
huh was he there too for that one no
just shooting a bird our cruise was
there though was he
no we walked and we popped we went to
see a movie try to be cultured a little
bit went to see that uh Colin Farrell
movie
or something okay how was it nice nice
film good yeah I'm a big and Bruges guy
I love him Bruges sure same guy Martin
McDonough Ambrosia guy too oh I love
ambrosia hopped over there yeah
nice little dinner no rezzy uh I think
she called on the way down to see if we
could get it they were like oh yeah 7
30. really yeah yeah huh easy peasy look
at you uh-huh not bad sniff them on a
tip and left with paper towels from the
bathroom French
hey frogs kick rocks huh
USA I'll take another side of Freedom
fries please
I was gonna say
better that Mayo neither I got my
own ketchup
bust out a bunch of packets
yeah I don't I don't belong I'm not a
cultured man I don't belong in those
places
here dude
she'll do the mod sticks
a couple ice cubes for that wine we
are silly but we got a goddamn family
out here folks
sign up for the patreon we want to
answer your garbage question Audi air
it's just the best way to do it we get a
lot of submissions the DMS the tweets
all this the emails the whole nine yards
people call my house one time and said
hey I got a question before it's easy
button snoozing over here uh but patreon
gets the first crack at it so when you
sign up we will answer your question on
the air sound good sound good let's get
into it what do you got Kippy uh this is
from a guy with the name of got robbed
the Norristown oh uh I've been there
before never have one red is it garbage
if the only place you could teach your
kid how to swim was an amusement park
wave pool
dude I wonder where that was in
Norristown I don't know it's got to be
talking about Dorney Park maybe that's
the only wave pool I know in the in the
tri-state area Dorney Park Hershey Park
probably had one Six Flags had one
driving up the Hershey yeah I don't and
I don't know if Hershey Park had one I
would assume they got a wave pool I
don't think Great Adventure did
did they yeah they did because I when I
was a camp counselor we took a a group
of kids and uh one kid wanted to wear uh
yeah which I refused again that had to
come later I thought Dorney Park was the
one that had the wave pull back
tonight
organization they got away
wall it's not Raging Waters or what's it
called T-Bone I thought you were I
thought you were about to sorry oh no
she's coming in a creek he doesn't
know he's a hillbilly Hershey
Park does have a wave pool but it's made
out of chocolate
there you go milky well they do have a
wave pool though but that's a tough one
learn how to swim at peanut butter Falls
hold on to the marshmallows I'd like to
see that in the Olympics huh the whole
town does smell like chocolate it does
it's nice there used to be an obisco
Factory up there on a Boulevard when I
used to live uh down that way in the
Northeast uh man you could smell the
cookies from a it's not bad
there also used to be a now and later
Factory in Brooklyn when I was you've
been thrown out of
there can you please please I pay my
taxes you're not welcome back now or
later that is storming the capital I
stormed that
trying to get in there yeah
um now there used to be a now or some
kind of flavor Factory or something over
it save it a flavor baby down here at
the flavor Factory there was something
over there in Brooklyn that he just
called food Factory's flavor fact they
got it all lime Cherry we got Cherry
they got grape they got Vanilla swirl uh
you should drive by the on the Gowanus
Expressway you could smell it in the
summer flavor Factory you are a great I
think it was now and later
I think it was now and later
but I don't want a brand specific
I don't want to pigeonhole them I want
to blow them up maybe they were runs
could have been a now and later dark
site I don't know I got my now and Later
Gators on uh teaching your kid how to
swim in a public wave pool seems Dane I
mean that's a real trial by fire who
taught you how to swim
I think I learn I don't know I feel like
I've always just kind of known how to
swim
uh maybe I have a Vegas use your head as
a buoy I have a vague member's boats
going around me
go to the left to Kippy stay watch the
week uh I think
we might have went to like uh when I was
like a toddler I have a vague memory of
being in like a pool at like a gym or
like a Rec Center type thing probably I
think I remember a kickboard now that
I'm thinking about it sure uh but I
think at that point I was already like
pretty good but I think it was more of
like
just learn some more fundamentals you
know what I mean I never remember not
knowing how to swim I'll never forget
the lady that uh that taught me because
set of cans on her now I
tortured her man she hated my
guts she had bruises all over I remember
them specifically what I was so scared
of the water man you are a oh
dude I pinched her all the time holding
me she I remember I vividly remember her
complaining to my mom like you can't
bring him back look at my arms I'm all
bruised up
in the kitty pool nah it was a big pool
I think it was at the cyc in
Wilkes-Barre is where I learned okay
imagine thinking you're drowning then
pinching somebody yeah I don't get you
that's my move getting handsy with the
instructor Wendy Peppercorn
yeah man I look back on it bad
news that's tough uh but then I got it I
took to the water like a seal yeah I
mean I just I had a record over there 12
and under freestyle for a long time
might still be dancing
did a worm like nobody's business doing
some backspins Maybe
pinching all the all the other kids
you're swimming against I remember
somebody loafed one in the pool
yeah like a Caddyshack we talked about
this uh we got in the deep end we used
to sunk too and they talked about it not
a lot of people know about it but the
greased watermelon we've mentioned it
before on the show the grease a
watermelon with Vaseline and throw it in
the pool and then it's like rugby or
like whatever you got to get it to the
other side of the pool and it's two
teams and man I remember just being a
kid I was too young and being like wait
till my day comes and I can get in the
goddamn grease watermelon man I
was all right there was a big day all
the kids would gather and watch it all
like watch like the older teenagers do
it yeah man and then one time we did it
you know those pretzel barrels
we felt without my buddy uh
Neil and Scott's house we filled that
with rocks and did it with that in their
own pool man I I sank I sank like a
stone dude I went all the way down to
the bottom with this I had to let go
maybe I got 50s gangsters oh man yeah
down there swimming with the fishes but
I remember in middle school when we
would do because we had a pool at our
Middle School
and we would do like swimming
certification at some point during gym
class throughout the year and it was it
was a pretty sized it was a pretty
decent sized pool and the deep end was
pretty deep it had to be 10 feet
something like that it had a couple
serious diving boards yeah and we used
to do
These Bricks they were like bricks that
were like made of like rubber and they
would drop them down it was like SEAL
training and we'd have to swim back and
forth and then dive down and get them I
don't think anybody has a car
seat with a seat belt you gotta get down
there cut it off roll out share
an oxygen mask dude that scared the
out of me Officer and a Gentleman with
Richard Gere all that anytime anything's
being done in a pool and it's empty and
no one's having fun I knew I'd never be
a pilot you never see anybody dive in
for Rings or something next door if
you're in a cage getting dunked
oh that's my biggest fear yeah brutal
but we had to go down and get these
things I don't think anybody did it and
I knew I knew it was dangerous because
they always had like two extra
gym teachers there with goggles on in
the water with their suits on like ready
to go down and get you I'm the
seventh grade here yeah just loaded up
on shitty pizza and a couple of
Otis by our cookies chocolate
milkshake man you got me doing buds
training you're ringing the bell
dropping out of school
dropping out of SEAL training man
look to your left look to your right two
of you won't be here you're like it's
room man relax Sparta what's
going on here I don't think they do that
no more no they got rid of uh they
switched High School my high school the
underwater demolition training
you're an underwater welder
down there with a TIG welder uh
watch the dinero movie with him and uh
is it Anthony of Honor oh man give me
those steps I was crying like a baby
back dude I was man
Antoine Fisher's nothing to shake a
stick act do you ever see that it's with
Denzel somewhere you're gonna kill him
shooting himself in the head oh is that
that one no that's John Q oh yeah trying
to save his cat's another one he don't
miss I'll tell you that might have been
the first movie I cried at oh I bald my
eyes like as an adult or like you know
as a man I think Kevin Connolly was in
that toe he was yeah he was all right he
was supposed to do the show hmm never
happened all right we'll get into that
what are you gonna do Kip how about them
Factor meals baby I got a text today
they got dropped off at the apartment
tasty and delicious gang Factor does it
all for you they shop for you they prep
it all for you yep they cook it for you
fresh never Frozen yep you go home you
pop it in the microwave or throw it on
the skillet for a couple of minutes it's
ready to eat easy peasy and they are
delicious yeah gang I got back on a
factor train they're fantastic it takes
the thought out of it I'm a big fan of
that chorizo chili they got cooking over
there you're gonna want to eat more than
one
oh they got delicious they got calories
smart keto options uh they are perfectly
portioned to keep you on track with your
goals Factor now offers 34 meals per
week and over three dozen add-on options
like sweet smooth smoothies smoothies
juices and so much more baby T-Bones on
them the 20D in under two minutes takes
it out if you're if you're wrapping your
head around should I get pizza get a
sandwich bada bing by the time you're by
the time your factory meal is done
you're already eating it you don't have
to make the decision head to
factorymeals.com garbage50 and use code
garbage 50 to get 50 off your first box
baby that's code garbage Factor that's
that's code garbage 50 at
factormeals.com garbage50 to get 50 off
your first box do it okay let's talk
about ladder baby
I love that ladder let's talk about what
you're leaving your loved ones yeah I
got you earmarked for a nice little care
package yeah take care of you for a
couple of weeks cleaning up your debts
I'm sure
in my ladder premium is going to be one
of them gang do yourself a favor get
yourself a little term life insurance
and if you're in the market get yourself
over the ladder and take care of it
don't leave your family holding the bag
yeah guys don't put everything off to
the last minute taxes Dental visits
whatever get out in front of it and take
care of it ladders 100 digital no
doctors no needles no paperwork when you
apply for three million in coverage
three stacks of high society baby just
answer a few questions about your health
and an application they've made best
life insurance on Forbes list in 2021
and it's easy to see why they got no
hidden age you canceled anytime get a
full refund if you cancel the first 30
days and the life insurance gets more
expensive as you age that's why it's
time to buy it right now so go to
ladderlife.com garbage today to see if
you're instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r life.com garbage
ladderlife.com garbage back to the show
back to the show
um all right let's see here this one's
from Peyton long time homie never have
one red are you garbage if you
exclusively used Heinz 57 catch up and
no other only because your father raised
stock cars and the number was 57.
here's my question about this what other
what else would you use them but I do
respect the brand loyalty not the number
he's talking about something different
we've brought this has come up before
and I've tried to clarify it and you
guys give me pushback there's Heinz
ketchup and then there's Heinz 57 sauce
I think that's what the guy's talking
about which is more like an HP kind of
sauce no but I under I I do it's like
more of the yellow or the reddish not
red like the brown yeah yeah yeah it
ain't ketchup Heinz 57 but on the
bottles though on the red bottles yeah
they have the 507 yeah they had 57
engraved on the bottles that like a
diner of the ketchup and you have a
regular Heinz ketchup yeah it would say
tap to 57s was the thing and if you tap
the 57s around the bottle it would all
come out huh okay no that's totally cool
it's because they had 57 varieties of uh
sauces
they did at one time they had 57
varieties yeah I mean there's 57 on a
ketchup bottle at the top says Heinz 57.
really let me say it that's what you're
supposed to hit to make it come out yeah
tap to 57s can I see it please so
there's Heinz 57 sauce right yeah and
then look right there
it says 57 up there that's right okay
yeah that Heinz 57 sauce was all right
me and my brother loved that I
don't think I ever with it but
not as a standard that would be wild
just using that all the time oh man if
you have to bring that you feel that in
the back that's Tang baby
no that's totally cool I mean dude
if it ain't Heinz
I don't know what to tell you I mean
there's not really a debate on that it's
not like the the ranch thing that we
were talking about no it's strange I
think there's a number like they make
like 98 of the ketchup in America and
they just water it down and sell it but
I'll do a hunt
yeah hunts is all right but especially
with the Pennsylvania connection we were
a Heinz Family
in the bottles for a while the glass
yeah that was pretty those got real
crusty
um oh yeah for sure it's like a bad
restaurant uh this one's from Jordan uh
first time long time not really a
question my mom was a grandma at 37.
I think she I think he said she had him
she had her she had his brother at 17.
and then at 20 his brother had a kid wow
to a 37 year old that's my age
that's crazy
a grandma but
she's still got her whole life in front
it's kind of the way to do it knock it
all out by the time you're 40. yeah man
chill now you got a homie you
can smoke cigs with and drink beer
there's there's people my age that have
their kids are like going to college
yeah well you're 50. that makes sense
47. well 46.
so if somebody had a kid at 28 it's not
bad yeah that's I mean probably most
people in America have their kids can I
get a number on that average age to have
kids in America it's probably 24. but I
have some friends that have just had
kids they're like two and three and five
28 28 huh average age man
hmm you gotta get cracking big man I'm
just gonna adopt an adult
new guy Luke
hey new guy Luke you're bunking up with
me he's all Caked Up up there he ain't
gonna come Uncle Hank's house yeah
kidding me but I need someone to need
somebody to take care of me
be out on the street what do you mean
take care of me when I'm older yeah I'm
really putting the screws to my nephew
about that laying the groundwork of the
game trip sure that won't him up
hey I'm gonna die someone needs to take
care of me
hey when I can't walk in three weeks
someone's got to take care of me someone
who's gonna wipe up the pee in the top
three weeks he's a freshman in high
school
uh uh all right this was well this one's
from H Hoagie never have one red is it
garbage you use a coffee mug for
anything other than coffee tea or cocoa
like wine or sodas oh yeah it's trash
though it's never enough it's it's a
perfect that's what I like about it a
Mug's a perfect container for coffee tea
hot chocolate sucks for water because
you're just standing by the sink for
three days trying to sure it's
not enough of soda if I fill that up
with soda you got a tea with dinner with
ice I gotta you get like a thimble worth
of Coke but there's something
there's something very edging about it
is that the right word is that what the
kids call it when you almost get there
check your Google search there when you
almost get there you're not
yeah that's all right with that what's
with some with some refrigerator ice off
the door the little Half Moon John's
sure and some sodi
for it's a little milk that's great it's
all right I would do one and a half of
those bro oh you're doing two for sure
not an
shout out the milk big fan love the milk
love it
um all right this one's from Scott H
brand new ten dollar homie a lot of new
ten dollar homies by the way shout out
to the Army garbage down there
like goddamn Gremlins man they're eating
after night dude they're all
they're doubling love it
um is it garbage to be from Northeast
Philadelphia like just a garbage
Birthright like nobility asking for
myself
is it garbage to be from Northeast
Philly it's Northeast Philly as a whole
is a tough
branch of the city I think great I think
as being a Suburban kid I want to be
more or less
it's a badge of honor
you got the Philly connection I don't
really have much of a Philly proper
connection I got my uncle by marriage
who's from down here Manny young man
young
but that's really it yeah and I was
always jealous of that I was born in the
Northeast it's where my roots go back to
Old School real dirt bags free decament
three deck a minute best yeah I mean
lace curtain most of my family is still
in the Northeast uh if it's not a great
uh it is there's great parts of it but
there's also Parts where you're like
hachimachi I'm not saying there hasn't
been an economic decline in the last 30
years and there's about a 98 change of
coming out of Dirtbag sure I'm not
saying that
yeah but it's nice to get a nice piece
of tomato pie every once in a while sure
of course you know what I mean head over
to Franklin Mills mall maybe know the
stocks family where you get the pound
cake from not too shabby yeah no it's
great I'd like to be in a first name
base with the lady at dalessandros sure
that's Roxbury Bozo same thing it's all
Philly it's still actually quite far
apart it's like probably an hour away I
love that Del Sandro
um it's all right yeah it's all right
yeah shout out to Northeast filling all
the uh they would growing up they refer
the the term going around was Newt they
called them newts what Northeast white
trash
a real Newt what's the great
Northeast is that different no that the
great Northeast is the Northeast okay
that was all marketing that was Gary
Barbera yeah I heard that on the radio
that ain't that great dude in the
great Northeast yeah made it sound like
beautiful that's where he had so Gary
Barbera was a he was probably still
banging uh yeah I don't run your mouth
he was heavy heavy I can say get run
over by a pre-owned Buick in Auto Sales
and uh him and FC Kerbeck coming at me I
love an FC car back Gary Barbera
it was the great Northeast and
Roxborough you know in the great
Northeastern beautiful Roxborough that
was all the commercials yeah yeah it was
all right I always wanted where the
is this place that's just the north it's
called great because it's huge it's like
well I'd go up on the roof and
look out and see if I can see if I can
see the Emerald City it's not I think
they're called the great because it's so
big it's like the size of the rest of
Philadelphia the Northeast is it's like
this huge this huge uh sprawling
uh area out there I just thought the mob
was up there I don't think so I don't
know the Russian mob now for sure
I told you they want me dead
uh all right let's see here uh this
one's from Brock is it trashy to walk
around a convenience store pretending to
shop for a while knowing I'm not gonna
buy anything and I just want to use the
facilities
uh a convenience store you're fine hey
you don't got to play that game no okay
where's the bathroom yeah
I think cause I do get this though but
from what since we've been on the road
so much it's like I'm just you just go
in nobody's at a convenience store a gas
station convenience store if there's a
gas station I just filled up what are
you talking about I'm about to got no
car I get five on dupe that's a mountain
bike
and I'm gonna go drop two in the
bathroom yeah be right out uh no you can
do whatever you want a restaurant is a
little different also somebody just
wrote in or tweeted or something that
the move in a restaurant is hey I'm
still waiting for my party I'm gonna run
to the bathroom real quick if you're
like jammed up I'll try that and a place
asked me to hold my credit card
you're a dirt ball yeah you walked Mike
Myers
you would have definitely walked them
who started to do Shrek and stuff
hey you guys need a body double by any
chance is it donkey with you
um yeah hotel hotel lobbies in New York
is a big one just pop into a hotel find
them yeah yeah yeah a restaurant room
1842 where's the a restaurant
all right as somebody who worked in the
industry for quite a long time
uh the way you play that is you just
walk up
don't I mean if you're if you're a
scumbag they're probably gonna say no
but if you're just looking to use the
bathroom hey I'm sorry do you mind if I
use the bathroom real quick most people
are going to be shorts right there yeah
you're gonna get a dick or two that
really doesn't have a reason to say no I
don't like that they just want to be a
that shit's so
and that used to drive me crazy
bathroom and you're probably not the guy
cleaning them I used to have an owner
the one of the one of the owners I used
to work for did that the nice
neighborhood there was no reason to
be like this like neighborhood
people sound like people are coming in
shooting up heroin or something no
nobody's graffiti in the you know the
walls or anything like that
and it would be dead there'd be nobody
in there like nah sorry and I just feel
like the you do like all I don't
understand coffee like a couple days
earlier that's another I think there's
there should be a thing of like
everybody's a potential customer yeah
yeah that's like I should be able to I
you know you should be able to piss and
in any Wawa I spent enough money at
this guy but like I said if somebody
comes in and they look like they're a
piece of you know
yeah if they're gonna smoke crack in
there or something or you know what or
you know they have spray paint out in
their hand that they're ready to it
and you're shaking a can of spray paint
yeah maybe Saints for customers only
I never understood that that always
drove me crazy I remember people like
YouTuber customers only like I don't
want to buy us I'll buy a slice but I'm
not doing it but like let me go
take a deuce real quick this is clearly
an emergency you know I'll get a slice
on my way out you know who's cool about
that there's a pizza place on
Third Avenue and 8th Street maybe you
know that pizza place Third Avenue and
eighth street it's on the right if
you're walking up near Cooper Square
yeah I used to meet you there after work
was on a billy club it was on like a
little mini baseball yeah yeah but
whatever I never understood that was
tough though man I would change in there
out of my those gray slacks that I stole
from my dad my shoes that had
holes in them they they were tough times
yeah they spent half my net worth on two
slices of chicken farm Pizza
shout out to it yeah and a screaming
cold can uh-huh no I never understood uh
the people that up bathrooms that
wrote on the inside of the wall
can I assume that you that you partaked
in that a little bit
you ever tag up a bathroom no no I do
appreciate some nice bathroom graffiti
you know look left look right the guy
holding your dick is a tiny dick or
whatever nah I hate that I mean
yeah if you're at Nobu sure but I mean
if you're at a dive bar that's all fun
and games I don't know
kind of the aesthetic of the Dive Bar
everybody tagged and someone else write
something they write something I worked
at that Bareburger in the West Village
and they people would come in and
do it all the time it's like
what the f it doesn't even make any
sense the are you writing yeah I
get graffiti nice picture nice
spray paint something nice but the tag
and it's like dude get some
Talent will you they do and they're
tagging and letting you know no that's
not Talent
something dumb
anybody can write you fatso
I was in the complaint department I
think I don't even think that was a tag
I think that was that was that was a
Yelp review you got yeah fat ass
that's just rude
uh all right let's see here this one's
from Sam uh is it garbage if your
neighbors have a fire pit in the front
yard smoking drink beers out there
almost every night yeah
listen there's nothing more I love than
a fire pit a cooler of beers and a
handful of heaters that's one of my one
of some of my greatest times in the
front yard but the front yard is a bad
look there's two kinds of people or
maybe side yard activity the side yard
who the hanging out on the side
it depends if you don't it's better than
the front yard dude there's two kinds of
people
front yard burners and backyard now
there's front yard people and there's
backyard people you don't want to be
front yard people no that's tough I
guess it does
depends slightly on the neighborhood how
it's set up
but for the most part yeah that's
fire pit in the front yard
there's definitely a car on the grass in
that yard sure yeah and it doesn't run
no I remember there's a runaway in the
house too
you probably just ain't seen Claire in a
couple of weeks yeah throw an officer
after somebody in that house
somebody's attendance is below Park what
was it true an officer were they cops
they have guns I don't think so I think
they were just more I don't know I mean
maybe some of them in certain places but
they were just more of like uh maybe
they were like a an arm of the like an
arm of the law Maybe
like I never went that far we had adopt
the cops in ours that was big adopt the
cops and adopt the cop I think that's
what it was called
um where each school would get a
neighborhood cop and like he was your
cop and he would come and talk and give
like whatever and they had like baseball
cards with this guy that guy was a real
fat piece of I don't want to say
his name
man this guy was a real tub oh Lord
I wanted to be officer Hoagie yeah hey
officer Hoagie dick get out of here will
ya
um yeah I remember just being like dude
this is a sham this is a puppet regime
what are you talking about give me and
there was another dude that we had this
cool ass cop officer Heath he
was the he would catch us
skating and stuff and didn't give a
you know what I mean he'd be like yo all
right you know the other people give me
your board where I'm calling your
parents our guy would come up act like
you don't even know me I'm like
bro I adopted you last year the
talk you're gonna call my goddamn
parents for doing a little for the
little board slider I'm wearing your
jersey yeah what the dude officer
he's would come back yeah I clear it out
what's up how you doing that's all right
that was all right but our guys sucked
ass dude dude it's so there's a lot of
requirements to become a truant officer
high school diploma all right fully's
out
I have a high school diploma
all right that one that one struck a
nerve probably a GED
well I was uh I think I was
the third lowest in my class
really I graduated with 348 kids I think
I was like 344 or something like that
I wasn't a show off uh really yeah I was
down here I remember the girl we had the
other four kids got hit by drunk drivers
four kids didn't graduate
because I think they did it they did it
uh they published ours because we were
505 and there was a girl at this
there's no she's probably not alive I
hate to say it but five of her and
another kid were tied for 505. dude it
was baby sharing the title oh man
it was like you couldn't I mean you
couldn't make we did make fun of her but
if you know there was party it felt kind
of bad I was down a good friend of ours
because they did that on graduation
Poppy's ours too they did that on
graduation that's where I found it out
it was like in the program or something
ours game it came out like right before
yeah yeah I think they lined us up like
that
they're reading the names Henry Foley no
holy you owe me 10 bucks
someone lost a bet
principal's like
I think they lined us up like that like
when we walked in graduation
no no but that's when I remember I was
tripping on acid too so I can't really
piece it together but I I'm pretty sure
that a preschool graduation
I'm pretty sure it was something like
that yeah because that's what I remember
that's remember what it hit me because
we all gathered in the cafeteria before
we walked we're already there
what's everybody doing in here that's
tonight
what
let's just grabbing some old Texas
Tommy's
we showed up we had it in the stadium
out there in Trojan Stadium shout out to
it uh in the stadium yeah in high school
oh and height like Heist football field
yeah football stadium yeah well as we
have a stadium driven balls in a gallon
man this concert blows Play Free Bird
dude
a tripping face
um no we have a state we have just I
mean it's not like United States
there was bleachers
is not a stadium
it goes all the way around full yes no
no no not the bleachers there's a
there's a fence all the way around it
they sold hot dogs they did pretty
pretty solid snack bar ain't gonna lie
Henry Foley hello
it's sauerkraut to you huh where's that
Beer Guy
hey throw a flag will you I'll be right
back I can get a TV timeout or something
go get a heater get my head on the
street because I'm tripping balls right
now oh man you're a different kind of
idiot excuse me is this real
no and then we go we all gathered in the
cafeteria before we walked out and
that's that's that was the first time
where it hit me where I saw it I was
like oh
and I was I was down at the bottom of
the list yeah yeah it's tough still got
my though suckers I was pretty I
was pretty up there I was definitely
like top
quarter or whatever we were out of 505 I
was probably like you know
120 or something like that probably I've
had a guess what about you when you
graduated from Bohemian Grove or
wherever you went to high school
we didn't have grades yeah man
so I got I got a frowny-face cloud or
whatever three kisses and a butt pad
three pine cones
um all right let's see here
uh this is from Hayden never had a
question right as a garbage to try and
get out of jury duty uh I would say it's
a must unless you got nothing else going
on you want to get jammed up on
a murder trial buddy of mine
just went through it the dude's
in there
I don't want to name names he's in
politics
a gentleman you know you have a friend
in politics I was joking oh but he's an
associate of ours of ours yeah
you know him is he a comedian yeah he's
a comedian okay funny guy you're just
talking about him right before the show
huh was it me am I injury Duty am I on
acid right now no but he was it was a
murder rap and the guy's in
there when they're trying to pick the
jury oh yeah that mug you dude
and now get caught up on a RICO case
that dude fish heads to
your your mother's door Bobby
bakala painting a visit when
you're at the snack bar with your kid
I'm not doing that that yeah I I've
never done it I got jammed up once when
I lived up in New York the first time
they brought me in found out you had a
warrant
no I'm on trial
yeah I said I had a dentist appointment
or something like that don't fly I got a
disappointment I did I think it was
pre-911 it was the wild west back then
or they were like uh does anybody ever
do when they bring me into like
interview you sit in a room
before they even bring you in sure
and you could be sitting there for days
seeing a people versus OJ and then they
bring you in and you're there with the
judge
and it's like do you have any reason why
you wouldn't be able to see this through
I got a dentist appointment in three
days out the door and a
reservation in about three hours
they catch a matinee down there at the
Angelica try to catch a table at rayo's
next week I can't really Jam me up I
gotta hop these ass lined up
sweet piece of trim yeah that dude
get out of that yeah you're just a busy
body from civic duty all that
that yeah I've never you don't want to
get caught up in that
unless it's something real juicy you can
write a book no I don't want to do
anything of that that's nope I
don't want nothing to do with that uh
this one's from Palmer are you garbage
if you take your CPAP machine as a carry
on a plane without the case
wow that's if you're raw dog in a CPAP
machine is it in your in your carry-on
it just says as a carry-on I think he's
just carrying on
his CPAP machine I wonder if he's using
it on the plane because my pulmonologist
said I could because they have plugs on
the plane
I feel like a real life pilot
can I have more tomato juice
[Laughter]
I have some more missed off cookies
please
don't talk to me while I'm landing
breaker one
some poor guy sat next to a 500 pound
Darth Vader
thank you
just tripping over your hose to go to
the bathroom gonna be nothing to stop us
this time
do that all day uh
yeah that's a tough look I want to get a
new bag for the for the new tour
Duff some no not that I want to get
something so it doesn't look like a CPAP
bag mine's getting a little ratty anyway
um get it get some get some new one
maybe like an all metal one well that'll
be cool handcuff it to my hand uh-huh
look real important sure
that is important it's the machine
keeping you alive what do you think I'm
a terrorist I get tased it's like I can
take a hatchet to your elbow make good
with the jewels
world's worst Heist you get back it's a
dirty cpaper hasn't been clean
since you got it I cleaned it pretty
regularly now since I got that bad chest
cold okay great from it
I got jammed up
I mean you play it fast and loose with
everything
talk about Sleeping with the Enemy man
inside of that thing looks like a bong
at a friend house yeah spray that thing
for for CPAP res
I'm doing CPAP res balls dude get your
eyes though oh god oh man that's
funny
uh all right this one's from Wildwood
truck nuts hey homies long time
stockholder never had one red is it
garbage to prefer your hands as a cup at
the bathroom sink rather than a real cup
it's amazing how waterproof your hands
are when you put them together I've had
that realization sometimes I'll do it
and just watch it slowly and it's like
that is that becomes a proper Bowl I do
I do enjoy the scoop of water but I
typically have a glaze I'm in the
bathroom let me say this as a kid in the
middle of the night you wake up and
you're dying to thirst and you go into
the bathroom the bathroom sink you let
that cold water run for like a minute it
gets screaming cold and you just put
your hands under it put your hands under
it and you just get in there and it's a
constant thing it's like slurping out of
a Babbling Brook oh my God that was all
right
um it takes it's like it takes you to
like an exotic place it's an out-of-body
experience
because I was I was real sick the last
couple of days and I had my little thing
with me with with the liquid IV in it
man just pulling on that thing
so good yeah
um yeah I I typically have something now
you have a cup in your bathroom no okay
you have a cup in your bathroom no I
don't like drinking the tap water in New
York why it's crazy safe No it seems
gross and old and gnarly you're from the
you're from the woods what are you
talking about that's where the clean
water is
right yeah well a lot of bears pooping
around here okay this guy uh
I I wouldn't go to the bathroom if I
needed water I didn't hear Aaron
Brockovich doing any reports in New York
City
um but they've got man shout out to EB
though shout out to Albert fitty um hell
of a performance Mr Steven Soderbergh
hear that kids drop ass in your high
school graduations you can make
references like that yeah you can make a
career out of making Aaron Brockovich
references deep cuts
uh Thomas Jane one of his early works
but well like now I wouldn't go to the
bathroom you know what I mean I think
like a Suburban House sure upstairs well
you're not going downstairs what what's
up that's how the Reaper gets
you he's waiting under the that
yeah man I would never cross that
staircase and then really what
what unless unless I was making eye
contact with the dog
be like it's me and you yeah
way there was dudes in every
corner down there and we had the open
floor plan so I could see everything I
didn't like that at all
I feel like with the because your house
is a split level that's like real urban
warfare that's like Higher Ground
looking down yeah dude no way it was
petrifying yeah not to mention you could
see the the other downstairs
from the top of the thing and it was
just
a black hole yeah yeah dude or seller
draft that man I wasn't going down
there for all the chocolate milk in the
world yeah no thank you I would get uh
uh sink down but now I just go if I you
know I typically have something but I'll
just go to the sure the bathroom but I
was always to them I was always jealous
of
like somebody who had a cup they had a
nice cup in the in the bathroom I mean
between me my brother and my sister was
like that's there's no way that's what
like you do if you're like married no
kids it's you and your husband or your
wife and it would be filthy if it was me
and my brother plus all of us taking
their balls in it or something you know
what I mean like it would be like
what do you think my parents
were doing I'm just saying like I'd be
like filling mine with Coke and leaving
it like it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be like you see in the movies
of like here's my glass of water I'll
put it down yeah fill it up tomorrow a
nice cold refreshing glass of water
before you go off he stops putting his
dentures in there when he's staying over
God damn man I opened up that jar one
day I didn't know I didn't what the
is this blue tupperware thing Hachi
Machi instead of jumpers
that was like a drunk 18 I was like a
drunk 16 year old
mother's in the science lab
my one ain't used to really play
it fast and loose with that she just
throw it in a rocks glass next to her
bed no lit or nothing I think it was in
barbicide or whatever I think it was
ginger ale yeah yikes just
having to sleep in her room just that
thing staring at me I swear to God they
would turn in the cup
start talking to me
yeah my step my stepdad my grandfather
used to get to scares as a kid he would
push him out do you know what I mean
yeah and it's like a three I
almost took a swing at him hail what the
are you doing oh man shit's
falling apart over there yeah my uncle
talk about my uncle would slide his top
ones out dude the lip drops oh yeah he's
like a different guy gives you a bitter
beer face real quick
you hear the suction on the lips go dude
like a different guy sick when a dad
shaves his beard and the baby freaks out
uh uh all right let's do a couple more
and we gotta wrapper up there this one's
from Tyler
um
is it garbage or spray ax body spray
after a poop instead of buying Febreze
I'm okay with it
well it's a tough I mean if it smells
like pooping teenagers in here yeah
that's tough I mean I'll spray anything
I sprayed Windex the other day
I'm a man I mean we we roll with the
matches I'll throw some scope on the
floor
I'll wipe it out with my socks uh I'll
wear a tip I'm a match guy ugh I hate
that yeah I don't nothing that smells
grosser than and matches I
don't get it at all I know we disagree
though it does matches smell like
sulfur it smells it smells your poop
smells like sulfur I'm not saying I'm
saying the sulfur diffuses the I
mean it's techno it's it's science the
sulfur diffuses that's technology it's
it's brand new poop technology
they did it in the old west yeah
because it was that good
they didn't have anything better they
were dropping like flies at tuberculosis
they didn't know what the they were
doing no but you go too heavy there's no
ice you go too heavy on the fruit I
walked in here you went heavy on the
Febreze today and I don't want to say
anything it's heavy you go real thick
you go straight away I didn't spray any
anything in here today somebody did no I
checked I threw the trash out that was
the trash bag yeah see it's got Febreze
on everything this guy I didn't make
them Everything You Touch goes to
Febreze now but you do spray too much we
have Poo-Pourri
what's that put little drops in the in
the turret that yeah before you do do
that doesn't do it that's I've I've had
that before you overpower that over Pat
yeah
take that like Sherman
blowing through a roadblock that's
oh no you put the three drops in
you're nuts wait till I spray that son
of a
Sheriff hot on your tail God damn that
song I'm gonna get him yeah
[Laughter]
kippy's Vanetta bone Tower dumps oh that
was a robber there was nothing or no
matter I'm gonna put poop to Nevada
Poo-Pourri and that wouldn't have
done not plasma yeah
spraying mud dude
got a bad case of mud butt
what do you want from me
um but let's wrap it up there
again what a fun time yeah we love you
love you boys come see us on the road
and gals and gal and I was talking to
you two idiots love you boys gang come
see us on the road we love you and we'll
see you next week peace